I'm Rick Perlstein,
I'm the author of Nixon's land problem
with Obama's postcards and agenda is
that he came into it,
he came into his presidency,
uh,
at a time when millions of Americans,
perhaps even tens of millions of
Americans don't consider a Democrat
president legitimate,
don't get sued or liberalism legitimate,
don't consider the idea of the state
farm new programs to help people
legitimate.
Uh,
so he's in a situation a lot like,
you know,
April Abraham Lincoln face in 18,
60 when you had millions of Americans
who didn't even consider what was going
on in Washington to have anything to do
with them.
So the big question for me was always
was this post partisan idea,
this idea that you could kind of bring
adversaries across the table and get
them to agree to each other and agree
with to get them to agree with each
other and,
uh,
achieve social progress.
Was that a deep seated belief of his or
was that in a certain sense,
a tactic?
Not a cynical tactic,
but a tactic and a,
I would be very with him if it were a
way of thinking about politics.
If the war,
a tactic,
because the job of a transformative
leader is not too huge the center,
but to define their own values as the
center as common sense.
And uh,
if he,
you know,
I,
I believe in the agenda he's passed,
he's,
he's putting far,
for example,
universal healthcare,
a cap and trade and green jobs as a way
to solve our energy problems while
growing the economy.
I think these are reasonable a while
liberal goals and uh,
if he presents them as reasonable and
the reaction to them as one could knew
they were going to be because there are
these millions of people that don't
consider a liberal president.
Legitimate was irrational extreme that
presented him an opportunity to say,
my program is rational,
but my opposition has chosen extremism
has chosen on reason and be willing to
take the hit that there's always going
to be a minority of the country.
Thirty percent,
35 percent,
even 40 percent who disagrees with him
radically disagrees with him strongly.
But if he's still willing to pass his
program with that 60 percent margin,
the rest of the country will eventually
catch up.
The reaction notice will understand as
they did with social security,
as they did with women getting the vote,
freeing the slaves,
you know,
social security that actually these
things were in their interests.
They'll accept them as part of the
established order of American society.
And in fact,
20,
30,
40 years years down the road,
the Republicans and the Conservatives
will be campaigning to save universal
healthcare,
just like a campaign to save social
security.
But the problem is this doesn't really
work unless you make this kind of
tactical shift.
If people say that you're illegitimate
and your liberal agenda is extremist
socialist,
uh,
destroying the America that we all grew
up with,
you have to be willing to say this is
unreasonable.
This is extreme.
And if you aren't able to say this is
unreasonable and this is extreme,
then you're granting your opposition a
undue influence.
You're basically negotiating with the UN
negotiator bubble.
And,
uh,
as Abraham Lincoln said quite eloquently
in his 18,
60 speech at Cooper Union,
uh,
you can't win that way.
I've been saying for years that,
you know,
there are millions of Americans who
basically don't consider,
uh,
the liberal project legitimate.
They consider it the opposite of what
America means to them and,
uh,
that they derive their identity from
questioning the legitimacy and the
ability of liberal government to,
to function peacefully.
So,
uh,
I think that for a couple months,
even more maybe six months,
uh,
Barack Obama's charisma and his,
um,
his remarkable popularity,
a kind of stunned,
some of these people into silence think
people couldn't quite believe what
they're saying.
But if you,
if you,
if you look at it historically,
it's quite continuous with what happened
when Bill Clinton became president.
You know,
when you began to hear people accusing
him of murdering his aids.
You know,
when you began to have,
uh,
people,
saying that he was actually a agent for
the Soviet Union,
which he had visited when he was a child
or when he was a teenager when he was in
college.
And you saw the same thing when Jimmy
Carter became president and,
uh,
you know,
um,
he was immediately considered a part of
this,
uh,
corrupt Democratic Party establishment.
Uh,
it happened every time a Democrat was
elected and it will happen.
Every time a Democrat is elected,
it's part of our patrimony as Americans.
And the challenge for a Barack Obama or
any democrat or any liberal is to
understand that this is just part of who
we are as Americans to acknowledge it,
to respect it,
and to transcend it.
And,
uh,
you know,
the lion can lay down with the lamb,
but it's not going to last for very
long.
Well,
tactically the,
the threat of,
by conservatives,
by social conservatives,
by the conservative movement as they
call themselves,
based in Washington,
based in,
you know,
uh,
places like northern Virginia,
to form a new party has always been this
kind of bluff designed to,
uh,
you know,
bend the Republican Party to their will.
And uh,
you know,
it's,
it's usually worked because the media
reports it seriously except for,
in the American context,
you know,
third parties very rarely work.
We have a winner take all system,
so you know,
the minute,
say wichard Viguerie who threatens to
create a third party,
you know,
every four or eight years because he
claims that the conservatives in power
aren't really conservative.
If he really did it,
he would immediately be surrendering all
his influence in national discussions.
So that's not really a serious threat.
Um,
the division between,
let's say a corporate conservatives and
religious conservatives is fascinating,
interesting,
rich and complex.
I mean,
one of the ways it worked was that
traditionally not traditionally,
basically,
one of the ways that evolved in the 19
seventies was that people who wanted a
business who wanted a more laissez
faire,
less regulation,
more control over government,
more of say a cronyism stake and what
government was actually doing,
um,
saw things like the Heritage Foundation,
the Christian coalition,
the moral majority as opportunities for
them to form a coalition.
Um,
if you give it a generous interpretation
or aggrandized their power,
if you give it a little more cynical
interpretation.
So you get these fascinating moments
like this.
A war in West Virginia in 1974 by
religious conservatives to,
uh,
to kick a heathen textbooks out of the
schools that were sort of supposedly
imposed by religious bureaucrats.
It was a very local issue.
It was a very localized,
struggled.
It had a lot to do with the way politics
works in West Virginia where you have
this kind of history of insurgent
violence from coal miners.
Um,
and you get these conservative business
conservatives in Washington at the
Heritage Foundation realizing that this
is an organizing opportunity for them.
The Heritage Foundation sends
representatives down to West Virginia
and helps put these people in touch with
national ideological,
large entrepreneurs with people like
Richard Viguerie.
And that's how a coalition forms that
basically creates foot soldiers for an
agenda that the West Virginia religious
conservatives may or may not be
supporting,
but eventually they'll come to support.
Um,
and uh,
it's,
there's,
there's both an inherent tension and
instability in it,
but there's also within American
protestantism,
a real strain of pro capitalism.
And so it's,
you know,
it's,
it's interesting,
it's rich,
it's tense.
Sometimes it works,
sometimes it doesn't work,
it's,
and right now we're,
you know,
at a real knife's edge about whether
it's going to work or whether it's going
to fall apart.
The CEO of a say in Aerospace
Corporation might not want to have
anything to do with a demonic
possession,
you know,
uh,
in pentecostal churches,
um,
but you know,
he needs the people who have those great
passions in order to kind of anchor the
conservative coalition.
So the question is,
when have they created a Frankenstein's
monster whenever they created something
that,
uh,
they can't control.
You're seeing more and more indications,
a buy from conservatives have,
you know,
that kind of embarrassment.
And I was out the other night and a West
Point Grad,
a banker friend,
uh,
who's a conservative,
he called himself the country club
conservative and said,
I have nothing to do with those Sarah
Pailin people.
Well,
the problem is,
without those Sarah Pailin people,
the Republicans would never win an
election.
So,
you know,
they find themselves on the horns of a
dilemma.
And,
uh,
the ideological entrepreneurs on the
religious right who,
you know,
uh,
let's face it,
have an interest in a grandizing their
power and their control,
uh,
don't really have any incentive to,
um,
to modify or moderate their positions.
In fact,
they're more likely to aggrandized their
power and their influence by,
uh,
by maintaining a front of purity.
So you know that,
that,
that speaks to the whole tension and
paradox behind the conservative project
right now,
all the people who have ascended to
positions of power and leadership in
rush lumbar is a perfect example,
even though he pretty much unites the
religious and a business,
conservatives pretty seamlessly,
um,
have achieved their influence,
have achieved their power through a
certain kind of cultural style based on
their willingness to say that compromise
is inherently bad.
And that gets back to the question of
whether Obama can negotiate with the 20
million people who listened to rush
limbaugh everyday and consider any
compromise,
compromise a betrayal of America's
promise itself.
Right?
So there's no incentive for a rush
limbaugh to change because this is
what's given him this,
you know,
these 20 million listeners,
his,
his mansion that has a,
you know,
a replica of the hall of mirrors at
Versailles.
So when,
um,
you know,
uh,
the Republican National Committee or a
train of a conservative Republicans who
wish to moderate the image of their
party to make it seem more centrist and
palatable to swing voters,
try and do that,
rush limbaugh is able to not merely
survive but thrive by disdaining them.
Healthcare is a fascinating example of
this question of how religious
conservatives and business conservatives
can act in coalition.
You know,
I'm being on the,
uh,
the,
the mailing list of,
uh,
you know,
the American Family Association,
Don Wildman Organization.
I'm beginning to get the emails saying
that know healthcare.
Uh,
they,
that,
you know,
basically national national healthcare
program is imposition on Christians.
You know,
it's going to do a fund abortions.
It's going to have a,
violate the sanctity of the traditional
family.
So you see a pure example of kind of a
right wing libertarian business,
conservatives,
uh,
using,
the leaders of the religious right in a
quite an effective way,
uh,
to,
you know,
undermine a mass constituency for
reform,
which in the end is actually quite
conservative.
I mean,
what could be more,
you know,
uh,
what,
what could be more judicious then,
you know,
like I said,
letting people change their jobs,
uh,
if they have an entrepreneurial idea,
what could be more strengthening of the
traditional bonds of family and society,
then families not going bankrupt because
someone in the family gets sick.
Um,
but,
um,
you know,
there are very powerful interests,
uh,
who,
you know,
basically benefit from the status quo
and they're able to take advantage of
this preexisting,
a deep distrust,
a that's,
you know,
very American of anything having to do
with an expanding state.
And again,
historically it's the same thing you saw
was social security.
It's the same thing you saw with
Medicare.
It's the same thing you saw with the
idea that the United States in the 19th
century should have a central bank.
You know,
the same thing you saw when the
government began talking about financing
internal improvements like canals,
uh,
the interstates,
you know,
which were seen as a communist plot by
some people.
Uh,
so,
um,
the challenge for progressives,
the challenge for people who believe
that this is,
uh,
not only,
an important goal,
but an imperative goal.
National healthcare is a not to imagine
that this kind of irrational fear is
going to go away,
but simply to both through it forced
healthcare down people's throats,
whether they,
whether they like it or not,
and watch what happens 10,
20,
30,
40 years from now when again,
conservatives come to power,
promising to,
uh,
to uphold the ideals of a Obama's
healthcare program.
Just like George Bush promised to uphold
social security and promised to honor
Fdr.
And,
uh,
just like,
conservatives have any gender,
every generation or I should say
reactionaries advantage.
Every generation say,
well,
the liberals that we're dealing with now
are unacceptable extremists.
Uh,
the ones we had last generation weren't
so bad.
I don't see it over the horizon.
And Reagan is a perfect example of
someone who simultaneously,
you know,
kind of honored the impulses of this
grassroots,
right,
but also kind of massage them and also
treated them like a politician,
treats a member of it's coalition,
like Franklin Roosevelt treated the
unions are Lyndon Johnson,
you know,
treated,
uh,
the civil rights movement and the
consumer rights movement.
Ronald Reagan was able to basically
massage the concerns of the pro life
movement without ever giving a speech to
them without ever granting them any
major policy concessions while able to,
you know,
being able to,
um,
place,
uh,
their acolytes in positions of relative
powerlessness,
symbolic positions,
you know,
things like smaller ambassadorships,
independent government commissions.
And,
uh,
with his criticism and skill,
he was able to,
uh,
mitigate the kinds of tensions that
created.
And there were tensions,
you know,
early in the eighties,
George will was one,
Richard Viguerie was another.
There were a lot of conservatives saying
that Ronald Reagan is betraying
conservatism,
which tend to happens whenever a
conservative president is politically
unsuccessful.
Conservatism never fails.
It is only failed.
They'll say that,
uh,
Ronald Reagan or George Bush.
It fails because they're not
conservative and that sentiment lasts
for as long as they're politically
unsuccessful.
But George Bush,
it's,
you know,
every other day you hear a conservative
say,
well,
the reason he failed was he wasn't
conservative enough.
Well,
the problem with that is a George W Bush
brought to Washington,
uh,
alongside a,
for most of his term,
a majority conservative congress and
quite conservative judiciary,
an entire movement,
entire set of institutions and entire
bureaucracy that conservatives have
built up,
you know,
in the years since Barry Goldwater.
So when George Bush is president,
he is not just a acting independently,
but he's acting for the figurehead,
for,
you know,
an enormous movement that was able to
insinuates itself,
uh,
up and down in the bureaucracy and up
and down the political chain.
So that's where the blame asked to lie.
Now with George Bush,
those kinds of people I come across once
in a generation and you can't pick them
out of a catalog and they can kind of
tend to come from surprising places,
you know,
certainly,
19,
62 when Ronald Reagan was,
you know,
it's washed up act going around from Ge,
planted Ge plant,
given patriotic speeches.
No one saw that it was him.
You know,
I don't see who it is,
but if I saw how it was then you know,
I'd be a,
you know,
a genius political consultant or I'd be
a great leader myself.
I mean a leaders see things in the
public will that are often invisible to
the rest of us mere mortals.
There will always be an American
conservatism.
It's completely continuous.
You know,
throughout our history,
it has its own shifts and changes and
evolutions in some positions.
You know,
that helped in the past.
It doesn't hold now and some positions
that holds,
holds,
it holds now,
it didn't hold in the past.
You know,
for example,
you know the concern,
if you're a conservative in the 19
thirties,
you're known as someone who didn't
believe in foreign military
intervention,
right?
You were fighting against the idea that
America should rearm for World War II.
Now,
of course,
uh,
you know,
conservatives are the people who are
most likely to,
you know,
call for a huge defense establishment
and be more eager to kind of go on
overseas adventures,
but something having to do with
individualism,
having to do with sort of this
fetishization of the nuclear family and
traditional values having to do with the
belief that a businessman's republic
kind of run a bind for businessman who's
a benevolence,
kind of trickles down to ordinary
people.
That's always been a part of American
political culture.
And it always will be.
I mean,
the challenge for progressives is just
to,
you know,
put together a coalition to make sure
that,
um,
you know,
the conservative coalition,
uh,
doesn't have enough power to,
to,
I would say a push through their agenda.
But it's often the case that they don't
have an agenda.
I mean,
there really is no conservative theory
of government as we saw for especially
the first six years of the Bush
administration in which,
you know,
basically had,
conservative hammerlock on the forces of
the state and all they were able to
really do was a weekend,
you know,
the state weaken our ability to
collectively solve our problems
together.
Well,
among conservatives saying,
your libertarian is always been a way to
say,
uh,
I believe in everything having to do
with conservatism except the
embarrassing stuff now except the stuff
except the,
you know,
the spiritual warfare casting out demons
from certain zip codes,
which was,
you know,
a big part of Ted Haggard's paradigm.
And the church,
the Pentecostal Church that,
uh,
Sarah Pailin is involved with.
Um,
so it's always been a more of a gesture
than anything else.
Of course,
the people who call themselves
libertarians within the Republican party
at least had been quite willing to go
along with,
you know,
these kind of violations of civil
liberties.
They have kind of gone along with the
war on terrorism.
Although there are,
you know,
genuine libertarians on the right who
have been actually quite heroic,
you know,
at preserving the principles of civil
liberties,
um,
you know,
on a,
among Democrats,
among liberals who find themselves a
enraptured by the concepts of
libertarianism.
Um,
it's not as good a fit.
I mean,
some,
some folks have been talking now about
libertarian,
liberal Terry aneurysm,
which is the idea that liberalism can be
stripped of its kind of paternalistic
elements and a respect the autonomy
people better.
Well,
the problem with that is that's always
been the ideal of liberalism and
liberalism at it's best and the
Democratic Party and its most mature
form has,
uh,
always,
you know,
attempted to create the maximum amount
of equality alongside the maximum amount
of freedom.
Now it's something that's often an
honored only in the breach because
that's the hardest thing for human
societies to be able to accomplish.
But,
you know,
I mean,
the,
the liberal vision,
you know,
dovetails with what's called in the rest
of the world social democracy,
which is that you can't really enjoy
anything,
uh,
like liberty unless you have some
minimum standard of living,
you know,
unless you're free to change jobs,
uh,
if you hate your boss and you're not
afraid of losing your health insurance,
you know,
that's neither paternalistic,
uh,
nor is it a socialistic.
It's entrepreneurial,
right?
So that's,
you know,
that's,
straight down the center of liberalism
and,
um,
that's something a libertarian would
reject because it involves expanding the
role for the state.
But a liberal at its best understands
that sometimes expanding the state can
actually enhance liberty in pretty
profound ways.